yeah while officer Tai was committed to
his police work he was also committed to
coaching the youth and that's exactly
what he did right here at Centennial
Hills YMCA as part of the dig this local
volleyball club
known him for about 10 years
and he's from the moment we met you know
we've been wanting to work together and
when you meet somebody you know you get
that Vibe and you get that that feeling
and he's just proven to me a superhuman
being that's Ray fafard director at dig
this a volleyball club in town Ray says
he's known officer trong Tai for years
his family friends and co-workers
mourning his loss as he was a key Staple
in the community and helped coach girls
volleyball in his spare time piffard
recalls meeting Ty years ago while
playing volleyball in town we started
off like in the recreation
the scene and that's how I got to know
him was we played against each other so
when he decided to coach with us
it was a blessing fearful Rosa and the
family it's just a tough time and very
unfortunate event I spoke to officer
Ty's fiancee Rosalie she too was a
volleyball coach at dig this she plans
to attend Saturday night's vigil and
shared with me that tie was quote her
person and the love of her life
as of now dig this volleyball club will
start matches back up in November now as
you can imagine the teammates and the
parents still reeling from this news as
it just happened many of them expressing
that they will attend tomorrow night's
vigil reporting live in Centennial hills
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now